Loki you're in a lot of trouble what do you want
from me come on sit down our timeline is in chaos
and you need the goddess mischief to help you Loki is unpredictable i know what i am good bad
bit of both here we are behind the scenes with Loki
that's me it's this really big story
with a mixture of tones and genres
loki's the god of mischief we have to do
mischievous things we're creating real mayhem
bye the tva oversees the sacred timeline
and keeps the order what if you take a
character who represents chaos and he
put him in that world you can't trust me
oh you've literally stabbed people on the
back like 50 times i'd never do it again
this is something i didn't think marvel has
ever done it is very different the audience
will be really excited this is the good
part i love the action there's interesting
characters there's twists and turns it's
awe-inspiring what could possibly go wrong
what did you expect
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new marvel loki trailer video they just
dropped a whole bunch of new footage and there's
a whole bunch of new details about the series that
we learned about and how it's connected to the
other marvel phase 4 movies like doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness and everything else
so if you're brand new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes starting next
week that's right episodes next week so be sure
to subscribe to get all those we're also doing
a disney plus giveaway for memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know how you think that loki is going to help set
up the other big marvel phase 4 movies with all
this time travel craziness going on but i love how
in this new footage you see loki trying to take a
shot at mobius the same way he tried to sneak up
on coulson during the first avengers movie when
he's getting ready to show him the recap of all
the marvel movies that's kind of what's happening
here like he's screening his life for him all the
terrible stuff that he's done so it's kind of like
doing a big re-watch of the marvel movies inmobius
just uses some of their time travel technology to
casually reverse loki back to the point where he
was a few seconds ago falling flat on his ass like
how about you pull up a chair as he just falls
flat on the ground it's a good example of how
advanced the tva's technology is and how easily
they're able to manipulate the timeline but i
love how owen wilson's mobius character here just
barely bats an eyelash like it's no big deal when
loki lunges at him then you see him talk about
the chaos of the broken timeline as they intercut
with what seems like female loki lady loki taking
out these other tva soldiers they're technically
called hunters like the ones in all the armor with
those batons because they hunt down people that
break their laws or people that are variants and
that exists when they're not supposed to exist
then you see them on this very broken looking
landscape with the purple sky it's not clear if
this is an alternate version of earth in some
post-apocalyptic timeline i believe it's meant to
be a version of earth like most of the series is
them jumping around to alternate versions of earth
but we do see them in asgard so there are a couple
different places that they go it's not completely
set on earth but i think the idea in this timeline
is that the earth has been strip mined over a
long period of time so maybe this is like an
alternate post-apocalyptic earth that they've just
turned into a glorified mining colony for asgard
where you see all these mining camps and the shots
being fired all over the place as our version of
loki and his tva uniform is running around trying
to dodge this and you keep seeing what seems like
a version of earth's moon broken in pieces as a
result maybe of over mining or war or something
terribly happening in this alternate timeline
it's also the same looking landscape when you
see loki sitting down with lady loki the shot that
everybody keeps mistaking for black widow there'll
be some lady loki scenes in the first couple
of episodes but i expect it to be a very agatha
harkness type of reveal where it took us a couple
episodes of Wandavision to really find out or get
some clues about what was going on with agatha the
harkness but the showrunner did talk about what's
going on with some of these alternate versions of
loki in the way they're using them in the story to
develop this main version of loki or technically
he's the alternate version but he's the new main
version in the mcu you see him get his ass kicked
by this hunter here that we've seen in all the
other trailers she's one of the main characters
too she even got her own poster she's not a comic
book character specifically just based on the
other agents of the time variance authority from
the comics from the fantastic four comics from
the thor comics even though you don't think of
thor as being a big time travel character the tva
did debut inside the thor comics then the tagline
of i know what i am bad good a little of both
which is a very apt description for loki but he's
also suited up in one of these futuristic looking
suits of armor like a loki designed suit of armor
that it seems like he's taken off of these other
troops that he just took out like if we're talking
about him going after alternate loki's in these
timelines whichever alternate loki they're going
after in this particular timeline has amassed
his own personal army and they just look like
this they wear armor that looks like this no idea
which alternate version of loki this would wind
up being but because it seems like this isn't a
far distant version of the future like it's taken
this long to strip mine this planet if it's going
to be earth maybe this winds up being the reality
that the older version of loki comes from there
was a rumor that richard e grant was going to be
playing older loki but they'd be doing it as more
of an homage to the classic version of loki from
the old school thor comics then there's that big
behind the scenes clip with a bunch of new footage
and scenes from the other episodes particularly
this futuristic looking blade runner style town
that we've got a glimpse of in some of the other
trailers no idea what this is actually supposed
to be but it does look a lot like that same type
of production design that we saw on contraxia the
vegas like pleasure town where the ravagers were
hanging out during guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
and i love this scene of what seems like him
summoning a roomba the way that thor summons
his hammer like they're in this roxanne version
of walmart that we've seen in the other trailers
and there's all those jokes in the other thor
movies about loki not being worthy not being able
to summon thor's hammer like in the first thor
movie when he just sets the hammer on top of him
to prevent him from getting anywhere only this
time it's him summoning a common household item
there was that deleted scene of loki summoning
thor's hammer which was just meant to be an
illusion that he was creating for himself to
satisfy his own fantasy like what would it be
like if i were worthy because he so desperately
wants the approval of odin he wants odin to think
that he is worthy they kind of pay that off during
thor ragnarok like that last conversation that
they have where he acknowledges him as his son
and then during avengers infinity war they paid it
off again where he called himself an odin son but
during the big interview that the loki showrunner
did about the series about how it interacts and
crosses over with the other future marvel movies
they talked about kid loki even though we haven't
seen him in any of these trailers the series is
supposed to feature a version of kid loki because
he is a big young avengers crossover character
i know a lot of people are wondering if they're
going to include him in future mcu young avengers
stories it does seem like they're building a
young avengers squad across all these marvel
phase four disney plus series i'll talk more about
that when we see kid loki showing up in episodes
just depending on what actually happens in
that particular episode but the way they
actually talk about the kid loki character goes
hand in hand with the way they talk about all
the alternate loki's so the showmanner said that
the actual story of kid loki in the comics which
was from journey into mystery is actually
good metaphor for this main version of loki
so in that particular kid loki story they're
referencing he's actually sort of taken over
by the life force of an older adult loki so
he's very literally and metaphorically burdened
with the past sins of a worse version of loki
that everyone hated in the marvel universe but
he's a little kid he hasn't done anything that
bad yet but he's burdened with all these sins
and that's kind of where this version of loki
the new main loki in the loki series picks up
they're judging him with the full weight of
everything that every version of loki has done or
will do because they can see the whole timeline
and they can see all these branch timelines so
it's like saying even though you didn't commit all
these crimes you're responsible for them in that
as he goes around talking to all these alternate
loki's trying to arrest them or dealing with them
he'll wind up learning more about himself from
the other versions like as he learns about their
stories how their lives wound up playing out he'll
wind up learning more about himself during each
episode as he slowly becomes a more complete
person on his sort of redemption arc the other
funny thing they talked about was the concept of
a loki love story running through season one love
stories multiple stories running through season
one in the same breath they discussed the idea of
female loki lady loki if you're not familiar
with a showrunner on loki he's mostly known
for coming from rick and morty but the thing that
actually got him hired at marvel was a script that
he wrote for a movie like a spec script called
the worst man in the world and it was basically
a time travel story it wasn't a marvel story it
was just a story about this time traveling person
that another woman had been sent to arrest and
those two characters wind up inexplicably falling
in love with each other as they're chasing each
other across time so a little bit of that energy
sort of flowed into the plot of loki because
people think of loki as the worst man in the
world so i don't necessarily think that that means
that loki is going to have a romance with the
female version of himself even though that would
be the most loki thing you could possibly do let
gimme loki but make it like a game of thrones twin
says story jamie and cersei would be proud and for
those of you that weren't really satisfied with
the explainer for time travel rules in the mcu
after avengers end game they actually said that
they had to refine the rules of time travel in the
mcu like they felt like avengers end game didn't
do a good enough job of explaining how time travel
worked so the loki series will sort of refine the
real rules of time travel but that will be the
new canonical explainer for time travel in the mcu
and if you didn't realize the showrunner for loki
also wrote the movie doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness he said that things happen during the
loki series to the mcu timeline that affect what
happens during doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness there are consequences that they create on
loki that he had to address during the script for
doctor strange 2 he didn't completely reveal
what those plot points were obviously not to
give away big spoilers but clearly it has to
do with loki jumping around messing with the
timeline as he's going after these alternate
versions of loki and because doctor strange 2
is literally called multiverse of madness there
will be chaos in the multiverse in general it's
just that loki adds the story dimension of time
travel to this whereas previously most of us were
just thinking about doctor strange 2 as being
a story where they just traveled to alternate
universes not necessarily them getting into the
idea of alternate timelines but if you really do
think about it i guess it's all the same idea the
multiverse alternate timelines just collapsing in
on themselves in chaos until theoretically you'd
have something akin to a battle world secret war
scenario now they're not doing the story of secret
wars for doctor strange 2 just to be clear even
though i know everyone would love to see some
sort of big multiverse secret war story line
in a future avengers movie it's just the broad
similarity in that the end result is the same
andy also said that doctor strange 2 as he was
writing that was supposed to start setting up the
plot of ant-man 3 with what was going on with king
the conqueror we probably won't get that first
doctor strange two trailer to like october because
the movie's not coming out till march but we will
get a trailer for it later this year but my full
episode one video will post next wednesday the new
episodes will post every wednesday there are six
episodes total leave all your video requests in
the comments below there'll be a couple more bonus
videos before that happens congratulations isaac
kabal you're the giveaway winner for my last
big marvel video please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for that brand new
thor love and thunder first look video that chris
hemsworth released and click here for all my other
loki episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!